love that Jiu Jitsu is getting a much  bigger platform and exposure especially  since the grappling arts in itself I  mean look wrestling is probably the most  popular one as far as especially North  America I mean we almost lost them out  of the Olympics there a couple years  back so I love to turn around and the  exposure they're getting and and look  and the fact jiu jitsu's big right now I  think you know the top that it's it's uh  it's Gordon Ryan you know I mean the guy  has really put it on the map I think  this last ADC proved that when you saw  him go out there and perform and so I  think that now with the momentum that  he's created in the sport hopefully that  can you know trickle off and a lot more  guys are getting exposure that are also  excellent Grapplers and can get uh bring  a lot of love to the sport  foreign